how to decide between the multiplicity
of options we all have in our lives
there are more things I can do with my
time than time I have to do them in how
do I choose and this is from Naval if
I'm faced with a difficult Choice such
as should I marry this person should I
take this job should I buy this house
should I move to this city should I go
into business with this person if you
cannot decide the answer is no and the
reason is modern society is full of
options so this is an interesting
reframe to the Paradox of choice yes
there are lots of things that you can do
with your time there are an unlimited
number of options this can make it hard
to decide on which option to choose but
it also reduces the pressure of all
decisions if something isn't an obvious
slam dunk yes then it's likely a better
option will come along soon as Derek
civas says if it isn't a hell yeah it's
a no the only caveat to this is it
doesn't work with time sensitive things
like having children